amidst phase Clan's ongoing Financial
turmoil and public infighting one of the
org's most OG members has leaked what
has allegedly Nick Merk's salary and the
number is wild
now before I get too deep into the news
today I want to let you guys know about
the brand new episode of our brand new
show into the dark presented by Kraken
rum this show is my baby I'm stoked that
you guys like it so much and this
episode is about nature it's about the
risk he took to jump start his career
and make it one of the most iconic in
the history of Esports click the link in
the description below to check it out
now unless you live under a rock you
probably know that FaZe Clan has been
having a pretty tough time over the last
year or so they took their company
public listed it on the NASDAQ
celebrated with a bunch of celebrities
as only they can and then their stock
price quickly plummeted this more or
less caused industry-wide Panic OG
members of phase started publicly
feuding with the company's corporate
brass and even esports's most decorated
veterans started asking themselves how
the can we make any money in this
industry their lack of success on the
market is a terrible thing for the
Esports industry as a whole man like
people look at that outside investors or
people that want to be a part of gaming
and they want to invest in it they won't
touch it with a 100 foot pole now one of
those members of the org who has been
publicly feuding with the suit wearing
accountant type people that they hired
to run the company is FaZe Rain suffice
it to say this guy has been on a war
path lately the guy has been airing
faze's Dirty Laundry wherever he can
whether that's discussing business
decisions that they made that he doesn't
agree with or just flat out leaking the
amount of money they're losing on each
of their Esports properties and that
hasn't stopped in fact recently he's
even upped the ante by claiming on his
Instagram story that FaZe Clan has been
paying Nick Mark's one million dollars a
year since 2018. and to be clear that's
just from FaZe that doesn't include Subs
donations or any brand deals he might
have on his own rain then went on to
claim that the reason they signed Nick
in the first place was to do damage
control for the very public contract
dispute they were embroiled in with
streamer T food that year in 2018. Rain
then went on a podcast where he further
discussed Nick Mark Steele and phases
struggles that's even like why I argue
that Nick Murph singing the beating I
have nothing against him but it's just
Nick Murphy's is somebody we have signed
but he was like a phase guy okay space
kid is signing a bunch of people
no we've had him but he's like the only
one that gets paid a lot and like I was
exposing the numbers he gets like a
million a year nobody else gets paid
anything because he's really big he does
his own thing like he's he does really
well and he's a business guy so that's
why because he knows what he's doing
right now I think there's a lot to
unpack here FaZe is his baby and he
wants it to stay authentic and cool and
he's frustrated watching the company's
corporate overlords run it into the
ground with sponsorships and
Partnerships and brand deals that he
doesn't agree with all while paying
nickmarks millions of dollars when he
isn't even an OG member of face he's not
even necessarily a name that Springs to
mind when you think FaZe clear with all
that in mind even Reign admits that none
of this is Nick's fault the guy is just
getting paid I'd be willing to bet that
Nick does more viewership than basically
anything else that face sponsors so
maybe that 1 million price tag isn't
really all that much and so for rain to
suggest that he can't really remember
one big moment involving FaZe and Nick
Merks might be a little bit of a
disservice to the size of this
guy which is the part of the statement
that Nick himself addressed on his
stream I'll say this I'm so proud of us
I'm so proud of this community I'm so
proud of my team I'm so proud of my
damn self man I I've I work my
ass off
people can say what they want to say man
but I've been up on top of the game for
years man I've been up here and
we put in work bro we do that nobody
else does we do it in ways that nobody
else does and and and and and we and
we've been doing this for a long time
and I'm proud of that bro one thing I
will say though
and some rain's position
real connection between FaZe Clan and
your audience is it really worth all
that money moving on from the specific
situation with Nick Merks and rain this
whole situation bringing phase back into
the news cycle has got the content
machine running people are out here with
to say on the one hand you've got guys
who are reasoned and measured and you
know want to share their opinion on the
state of the industry like nadeshot I
think FaZe is gonna be okay long term I
I mean I hate to see like the original
creators uh have such a sour taste in
their mouth
because it's really hard for these kids
that grew up
building this thing and then you know
they take on Capital they raise money
now there's more people at the table
people at the table that they don't
think belong there
and if you know Tico and Rain aren't the
guys that are actually vetting who's
coming in and investing in the business
and who's running it day to day
you know that's a tougher situation for
them to be in and then on the other
billion dollar business I could create a
team from zero I could buy facecon
tomorrow for 50 million and I could make
that a billion dollar company in two
years without a glimpse of that
ultimately I think the question on
everybody's Minds mine particularly is
this will face Claire perhaps the most
well-known Esports org in the western
world
sold soon and if that's the case then
how on Earth can other companies expect
to break through that threshold I want
to hear from you guys on this one I'm
gonna be down in the comments if you had
controlling interest if you could do
whatever you want with one of these
Esports orgs what would you do to make
sure they could turn a profit
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock